[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
tout faire pour éviter un prochain black
out électrique
cet hiver réseau de transport
d'electricité de france a placé le pays
en vigilance particulière et ce jusqu'en
le risque latent est celui d'un black
out
la raison
une conjonction de facteurs à savoir la
rénovation du parc nucléaire l'usure des
centrales à charbon les retards dans les
projets éoliens et solaires ainsi que
dans celui du chantier de le p r de
flamanville ou encore la réduction
globale des capacités de production
pilotable à l'échelle européenne
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat s'alarme de cette situation qui
nuit à notre transition et à notre
indépendance énergétique et qui comporte
de l'eau risque pour tous les
consommateurs d'énergie ménages
entreprises collectivités territoriales
elle est d'autant plus inquiète que
selon elle cette situation risque de
persister si les orientations politiques
ne changent pas
car si la commission relève des causes
conjoncturelles liées à la crise de
l'aco vidé à la guerre en ukraine elle
souligne également des causes
structurelles liées selon elle au manque
d'anticipation du gouvernement et à son
désintérêt pour la filière nucléaire
rte a souligné la disponibilité
historiquement basses du parc nucléaire
cet hiver en raison d'un arrêt des
réacteurs mais aussi de contrôler rendu
nécessaire par la découverte d'un
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
soit des fissures sur l'acier de
certaines tuyauteries
dans ces circonstances la commission
regrette la fermeture de la centrale de
fessenheim jugé pleinement fonctionnel
sur le plan de la sûreté et note par
ailleurs que les objectifs en termes
d'énergies renouvelables n'ont pas été
atteints
si elle ne nie pas l'existence de
tensions équivalentes chez nos voisins
européens
la commission note une vulnérabilité
spécifique à la france et proposent pour
s'en prémunir trois grands axes de
réformes
il s'agit d'abord de réviser l'ensemble
du cadre stratégique en offrant
notamment un cap clair des actes
concrets et des investissements massifs
à la filière du nucléaire
elle défend ensuite une consolidation du
système de sécurité d'approvisionnement
avec une évaluation précise et complète
de l'impact de la crise de lakovic 19 et
de la guerre en ukraine
enfin elle considère qu'il faut
mobiliser les leviers de pilotage de la
production et de la consommation
en appliquant les appels d'offres en
soutenant les aident à l'efficacité
énergétique et en recherchant une
complémentarité d énergie avec un regard
particulier porté sur le biogaz
l'hydroélectricité et l'éolien en mer
pour en savoir plus et découvrir les
douze recommandations de la commission
consultez la synthèse du rapport
[Musique]